hi I'm Barton Seaver chef and National
Geographic fellow welcome to cook wise
the Chesapeake Bay was once famous for
its oysters still is but populations are
1% of their historical levels not only
is this devastating for fishing
communities it's also harmful for our
oceans moistures could make a comeback
through the efforts of people like Ryan
and Travis Croxton owners of
Rappahannock River Oyster Company
they're working at a fourth-generation
hundred-year-old family tradition trying
to keep the Chesapeake oyster not only
on the map but on our plates great to
see you guys again let me show you how
we're trying to make it different great
I'm excited to see this
it's not all aquaculture is the same and
you chose a cage method for your oysters
tell me about that we wanted to do
something was as close to natural as
possible so our oysters grow just like
the wild ones do just in a cage and we
pull the cage up will actually show you
they're creating a little reef
environment just like you would in a
major reef environment we're just doing
it on a smaller scale and so we don't
have to dredge the the bottom to get
those oysters back we just lift cage and
now our your oysters helping to reseed
made of wild populations yeah we're
definitely that was one of the things
that we were key on we wanted to have
not just a business strategy for the
restoration strategy so so it's so it's
really about you know being able to give
back and then be able to make money off
of it as well we're not kidding
ourselves this is a business but if we
can be doing something each one of these
where do they produce like a million two
now eggs one oh sure great so I mean all
that stuff is just going out into the
bay let's eat some of this restoration
boy stirs are the great recyclers of an
ecosystem they filter nutrients out of
the water column and thus fix it in the
environments millions and millions of
oysters at their historical population
cumulatively filtered the entire Bay in
just a few days but currently the low
levels and devastated populations of
oysters it takes almost a year to do the
same process Wow these look great
each compartment can hold 500 market
size moisture so it also helps with the
chef's fulfillment they call us we
harvest it we know exactly what's out
here and they know what they're getting
there's no variables with how much kind
of catch today it's farm protection
video issues so that you know stingrays
and things like that that would
naturally want to come after an oyster
can't get to it
uh-huh and with this jostling around of
all these oysters and the times it would
work with throughout the year you get
this really cool effect of your chipping
off this outer bill growth it starts to
shape the oyster so unlike a wild oyster
which is gonna grow in a clump and grow
all this shaping because it's trying to
plate your food these get to sit rather
lazily in here and have food brought to
them and kind of a moron growing deeper
so more concentrated on meat grows
rather than show growth and these look
so fantastic I can't wait to try one you
mind dig it man enjoy now shucking an
oyster a lot of people think this is a
really difficult task we just go knife
right into the back shell finish it up
and then slice off that top shell and
look at that beautiful beautiful oyster
let's go
that is so so good we're gonna do with
the shells garm overboard go to reef
best litter in the world right now
if Roy stirs cold sweet wonder isn't
your cup of tea come on back in land
with us we're gonna be cooking them up
with a little bit of peaches on the
grill one of my very favorite things in
the whole world is grilling today we're
gonna be taking those oysters just
plucked from the water we're gonna be
grilling them with a little bit of
smoked paprika and peach simmered in a
little bit of butter but what really
makes a meal is the vegetables and I've
tossed a little bit of red onion lemon
slices and some corn and the olive oil a
little bit of salt and just thrown those
on so this is butter in paprika smoked
paprika or pimenton Spanish the Spanish
ingredient that I absolutely adore it's
got a smoky sweet flavor to it that
marries perfectly it's like bacon - the
bacon with everything you love about
bacon win-win now I got my vegetables
started way ahead of time so that they
had time to cook all the way through
boys don't take but more than five
minutes to cook and we've got a just a
slowly smouldering fire here with the
coals we're gonna put these peach top-2
oysters right on top here that butter
gets down there and flames up a little
all right four minutes and we're good to
go
punk-ass looks good I'm excited to be
sharing the oysters with you we got here
environmentalism on the half-shell we're
storing the river one delicious oyster
at a time good for us good for the
environment and good for families too
you know this is what I call family
tradition I love it for recipes tips
techniques links and seafood stories
visit us at National Geographic comm
forward slash cook wise to join us in a
global effort to protect the ocean go to
I am the ocean org remember delicious is
the new environmentalism so cook wise
you